nous sommes dans le quartier blockhaus
et un quartier très populaire dans le
nord d'abidjan ou fonctionnaires
ouvriers et étudiants ont l'habitude de
se retrouver autour d'un plat dans les
maquis une véritable institution ici en
côte d'ivoire mais bientôt sur ce monde
pourrait se voir contraint de présenter
un test pcr de moins de 72 heures ou un
certificat de vaccination pour pouvoir
se retrouver entre amis quoi ont conclu
à quoi quand on est obligé de faire le
vaccin sinon c'est la cata quoi mon
personnage - je compte
bien moi que les sels et bien expliqué
et puis j'aime le repas qu'ils imposent
et chacun de vivre de fait son choix
mais si la liberté du milieu doit
empiéter sur la liberté de tous arrivé
sur mon fils est en cause la liberté
individuelle
passe un test c'est un peu bizarre en
indiquant copie tout si l'occident en
fait c'est aussi bien pour nous parce
que ça ça nous protège à nous
responsabiliser aussi donc je suis prêt
à le faire si les avis sur ce pass and i
ter sont mitigés côté clientèle du côté
des restaurateurs la perspective de
cette mesure inquiète une profession
déjà fortement impacté par la crise
sanitaire c'est le cas de jean jacques
biaggi patron de l'espace port royal il
craint de voir la fréquentation chuter
drastiquement
c'est le guen monza
on voit des améliorations pour truc que
gérer on peut gérer avec
ses je suis jeune et soit 2 500 700
personnes on me dit bon des fois que tu
réduisent à peut-être à 300 à 400
personnes je peux retraités mais sommet
dit du réduit à 100 personnes ce que je
vais faire mais bon si c'est dans
l'objectif de
préserver de la maladie on objet de
faire on va demander pas s'arrêter à
chaque personne et s'il faut même ça
sera comme un passeport on entre dans
l'espace depuis le 20 septembre tous les
voyageurs en provenance ou à destination
de la côte d'ivoire doivent être munis
d'un pass avec qr code dans ce centre de
formation de l'institut national de
santé publique dans la commune du
plateau une quarantaine d'agents sont
formés quotidiennement pour renseigner
la population sur le pass sanitaires et
rassurer ceux qui restent méfiants
vis-à-vis des vaccins anti qu'ovide
qu'aujourd'hui pour pouvoir venir boucle
de cette pandémie c'est la vaccination
dont c'est surtout emmenés la population
à se faire vacciner et surtout faciliter
l'accès aux sites de vaccination aux
populations à la longue en fonction de
l'évolution de la pandémie chez nous on
verra s'il faut casser les mesures pour
imposer un pass and it et ou par pour
entrer dans les lieux recevant du public
dans ce pays de plus de 27 millions
d'habitants seuls 6 % de la population a
reçu au moins une dose de vaccin à ce
jour le gouvernement ivoirien qui a
commandé plus de 12 millions de doses
mais qui en a reçu que 2 5 millions ce
qui rend l'objectif de vacciner au moins
un million de personnes par mois
difficiles à atteindre